Speaker 1: So we've talked quite a bit at
this point this week about the death of former
Secretary of State Colin Powell, we've talked
about the political side and Powell's legacy
as someone who, while he found some areas
of reason since the Obama era and defending
Barack Obama against misplaced Islamophobia and
criticizing Donald Trump for the absurdities that
Donald Trump was, he was really one of the
main perpetrators in selling the Iraq War to
the American people in the global population.
We talked about that, so that was one piece.
Second piece was the medical side anti-vaxxers
swarming to weaponize the death of Colin Powell,
saying, Look, the vaccines don't work.
He was vaccinated. He died, of course.
Eighty four year old with both cancer and
Parkinson's does not really prove or disprove
anything about the effectiveness and efficacy of
vaccines at a population level. So those have been
the two big stories. Well, the former president
Donald Trump has now come out of the woodwork and
has put out just a disgusting statement
about Colin Powell. Now my view on this
is this is sort of like regardless of what
you think about the politics of Colin Powell,
this is a disgusting statement from a former
president, which we will look at, as USA Today
reports. Amid tributes to Colin Powell, Donald
Trump disparages former secretary of state.
A day after the death of former Secretary of State
Colin Powell, former President Trump disparaged
the diplomat and decorated general. In a statement
released by his office, Powell died Monday
of COVID complications. Trump's statement echoed
his actions after the deaths of other prominent
Americans who he considered foes, including
Senator John McCain. Civil rights icon John Lewis
and Congressman John Dingell, or Dingell Dingell,
who was the longest serving member of Congress. So
let's take a look at the statement from Donald
Trump because he is off Twitter and on Facebook
and off who who knows where else he's off, and
his blog failed miserably. Donald Trump puts out
these statements through the Save America PAC PAC.
That's another grift under which he raises money,
supposedly to do good things for someone,
and he seems to keep most of the money. OK,
so he put this out yesterday. Statement by Trump
OK. Wonderful to see Colin Powell, who made big
mistakes on Iraq and famously so-called weapons of
mass destruction. That's true. Be treated in death
so beautifully by the Capital F fake news media.
Hope that happens to me someday. He was a classic
rhino. Rhino, again, is a Republican in name only.
If even that always being the first to attack
other Republicans, he made plenty of mistakes. But
anyway, may arrest it. May he rest in peace. And
right below, you can donate to the Save America
PAC if you like that statement from Donald Trump.
We're back to zero days since former President
Donald Trump was a national embarrassment.
I genuinely thought this one was fake. I really
thought this was fake because it's so absurd,
but it's real. It's it's horrifyingly real. And
I sort of laughed to myself thinking back to when
we were told after some Trump speech this was
like 2017. He's clearly now moving to be more
presidential, more sober and a more adult and
all of that stuff. That was like four years ago,
and it obviously still has not happened. And this
is essentially basically an envious reaction to
coverage of Colin Powell's death. As the USA Today
article mentioned, Trump attacked John McCain
for being a prisoner of war while John McCain was
alive when John McCain passed away. Trump still
had bad things to say about John McCain. It's not
a huge shocker. This is not about we can't make
substantive policy critiques of people when they
die. This is not about in the case of really bad
evil people even saying, Hey, you know what? When
Rush Limbaugh died, I don't wish death on anyone.
I don't wish the the trauma of that to people's
family. It's not me to wish for someone's death,
but I can recognize that they were a dramatically
damaging influence on society, as was Rush
Limbaugh. We can do that. And similarly, with
Colin Powell, someone who I found to be, generally
speaking, an intelligent guy, interesting
to listen to on many topics and someone who
as a Republican, maybe opened some other
Republicans during the Obama era into re
considering or reexamining some of their beliefs
by saying, Hey. Not only is Obama not a Muslim,
what if he was it's kind of un-American
to say, then he shouldn't be president,
pointing out that Donald Trump doesn't
represent, you know, kind of Mitt Romney,
John McCain type republicanism like these are
reasonable things to say and a salesperson for
the completely misguided war in Iraq based on
lies about weapons of mass destruction. And
we can recognize all of those things. But to
see such a disgusting envy, obviously envious
statement from a former president very much on
brand for Trump, very much in line with what
we've got, we've come to expect. But
absolutely and completely disgusting.
Let's talk about this continued battle over
documents about Donald Trump's actions leading up